- Thank you.
(audience cheering)
Hey everybody, how's it going?
I'm Brandon Wright, I'm a
product manager at Equinix,
and I focus in our fabric
network as a service platform.
- I'm Ranga Thittai.
I'm the network go-to-market head at AWS.
- And today we're gonna be talking about
building high-performance, secure networks
for hybrid and multi-cloud.
So super quick, just a
quick agenda overview.
Ranga's gonna start us off and talk about
some customer use cases
of what they're seeing
around Direct Connect,
as well as data movement considerations,
Direct Connect, VPN, internet,
and things like that,
and what we see, behaviors,
and looking at scale and time.
And then we'll look at the case
for private hybrid multi-cloud,
including some use cases and examples
that we have on our
side with case studies.
And we'll talk a little
bit more about Equinix,
as well as some of our products
and the history behind Equinix,
and where we came from,
and where we are today.
I'll hand it over to Ranga.
- Thank you, Brandon.
Let's start off by
looking at the importance
of large data movements,
as it relates to your
go-to-market initiatives.
We all know about gen AI,
whether it's model training,
foundational models, if you're an ISV
or an FM provider, you're
training your models.
If you're an industry enterprise,
you're probably looking
at RAG initiatives.
You're building your RAG vector stores,
and that requires a lot of data movements.
You're consolidating your data
into centralized environments in AWS.
Talking of industries,
it's probably a cliche
to state that industries run on data.
But just to quote a couple of examples,
our automated vehicles,
connected manufacturing,
media digitization, media
production in the cloud,
all of them require large amounts of data
to be moved to AWS, perhaps
even on a continual basis,
right?
But across industries, perhaps
the most common use case
that we all come across is migrations.
When you're doing your complete
migration to the cloud,
you're moving all your
data estates to AWS.
It's not surprising to see
some of these requiring
hundreds of petabytes of
data to be moved to AWS
within a matter of six to nine months.
And to achieve that, you need reliable
and high-bandwidth connectivity
to achieve those objectives.
Today, we'll talk about AWS solutions
as well as partner constructs
that enable these kind of use cases,
as well as network constructs
that allow low-latency connectivity
for distributed workloads
as well as distributed data access.
We look at some of the
characteristics of these solutions
and as well give you a couple of ways
to try them out, perhaps, as well.
Let's look at gen AI.
It's a hot topic.
So if you're engaging in model training,
Swami talked about frontier
models this morning,
which make you develop
those models from scratch
specific to your industry domain.
If you're an ISV or a
SaaS provider for AI,
you're also training your models
or fine-tuning your models.
If you're just an industry player,
you're looking to leverage
some of the foundation models
but create your own drag vector stores,
that also requires a lot of data
to be moved from hybrid ecosystems,
hybrid environments, multi-cloud
environments into AWS.
When it comes to inferencing,
you could also be engaging
in distributed inferencing, right?
You could be looking at hybrid drag
if you are compliance-oriented
or you could be considering hybrid EKS
if you are looking to
leverage distributed workloads
across hybrid environments.
In these cases, you're looking
at real-time interactions
and in these kind of situations,
getting a performant and
deterministic networks
becomes important so
that you're delivering
a consistent user experience
through that network.
That brings us to Direct Connect.
AWS Direct Connect is a
dedicated network path into AWS.
It avoids the internet.
It's basically not subject
to internet weather
and therefore delivers consistent
performance all the time.
It offers an availability SLA,
so for critical projects
like we spoke about,
you're guaranteed almost
to have a continual available
connectivity all the time
to get your end-to-end project done
or if you are distributing
those workloads,
mission-critical workloads,
and you need that consistent performance,
you're getting that all the time, right?
There's an extensive
coverage of this offering
available in more than 30 countries
in the excess of 100 locations.
Finally, it's also encrypted in layer two
through MAC encryption.
We call it MACSEC,
so it's particularly useful
in the case of compliance
space-specific use cases
where despite that dedicated connectivity,
you want your customer's data
to be moved in a compliant
encrypted fashion as well.
Let's put AWS Direct
Connect in the context
of those use cases that we
discussed initially, right?
So let's start by looking at a simple
10-petabyte data move, one session, right?
So, later on, we'll talk
about hosted Direct Connect
as a very simple turnkey
construct that partners host
and they just carve out
for customers like you,
but a hosted Direct Connect
offers a bandwidth of 25 gigs
and with that, you'd be able
to achieve this transfer
in one hour, right?
But if you're using a VPN
connection over the internet,
you're looking to get the same thing,
you're probably about 5% progressed,
assuming that availability
stays 100%, right?
Now, imagine using this
benefit 1,000 times
for a 10-petabyte
migration project, right?
So that adds up, that reliability
and that ability to move that data fast
for each of your little data islands
as you prepare them and you curate them
and you move them into AWS,
that benefit adds up if you consider that.
When it comes to distributed
workloads and data access,
AWS offers the shortest path.
It's also a dedicated connection.
Therefore, it offers that
performant connectivity
that you're required to
give that consistent latency
or response time, especially
when it comes to workloads.
We heard Swami talk about response times
of these gen AI agents.
You don't want your network to be adding
to that response time and latency as well.
All right, so how do you get your data
and your distributed environments
connected to AWS through Direct Connect?
And that's where our partners come in.
Our partners offer that
turnkey connectivity
to get you connected quickly and easily.
Based on your use cases,
the connectivity models they offer
are also elastic.
They can also be customizable
based on your render choices as well.
With that, I pass this back to Equinix,
our sponsors for this
session, to take this forward.
- Thanks, Ranga.
All right, team.
Talk a little bit about why Equinix,
a little bit of history of Equinix.
Been around for about 26 years.
Started out as internet exchange.
Network service providers
came through and said,
hey, trying to interconnect.
Growth of the internet was exploding.
And Equinix was that neutral
interconnect provider.
That business continued to grow.
And soon after, we had customers
interested in connecting to public clouds,
public clouds as partners.
And again, Equinix being a
neutral interconnect partner,
we're able to provide connectivity to AWS
and many others, cloud
providers, service providers,
network service providers.
And then over time,
we've grown to 11,000 plus enterprises
using our platform.
And then beyond that,
it's allowed us to create
what we have today,
which we call Equinix Fabric.
This is a network as a service platform,
available across 270 plus data centers
in 36 countries,
spanning 75 different
metros and six continents.
This is a completely global
software-defined network.
And of those, we have 220
or more cloud on-ramps,
including AWS.
56 of those are AWS Direct Connect.
You can see them.
They're little off-color
there, squares on the map.
And those are areas where
we have direct on-ramps
from our data centers in
our Fabric network to AWS.
And across our global network,
we're using more than 2,000
fiber and telco networks.
All of that combined and providing
that level of connectivity
and reliability allows
us to offer a five nines
global uptime and reliability SLA.
As part of our fabric network,
one of the newer products
that we've launched
in January 2024 is our
fabric cloud router.
This is a completely
service-based solution.
Doesn't run on virtual appliances.
There's no licensing.
There's no other hardware
required from the customer.
It allows you to on-demand,
turn up instances in the
metro that you wanna deploy
and create your connections from.
It does this within minutes.
And it's fully distributed and supports
natively high-available connectivity.
So primary and secondary
data path connectivity
that is completely independent end-to-end.
We offer various different
packages and tiers
depending on the performance
and route scale requirements
that customers have.
But that allows us to
offer multiple different
very economical options for FCR.
And then from a scalability perspective
in terms of throughput,
we offer everything from 50
megabit individual connections
all the way up to 100 gigabit
individual connections
in an aggregate supporting
greater than a terabit
of aggregate throughput
across that single cloud router instance.
So as we look at different on-demand
hybrid multi-cloud connectivity,
we have customers that are
deployed in multiple metros.
They can deploy a cloud router,
they can interconnect with
their co-located infrastructure
via Fabric Port.
They can do that at up
to 100 gigabit today.
And then they can also connect
to different cloud providers as well.
One of the benefits here
is that customers that may
have traditionally interconnected
between AWS and maybe a
secondary cloud provider,
they were doing routing in BGP
back to a co-located infrastructure,
a co-located router that they had.
Maybe it was within an
Equinix data center,
maybe it was all the way back on-prem,
which meant any
connectivity that was routed
between the two cloud providers
had to effectively hairpin back
to wherever that router was.
And that's where Fabric
Cloud Router comes in
and provides extremely low latency
and interconnect as we have local on-ramps
with multiple cloud
providers across our metros.
And then looking a little bit
more into the performance,
on the right you'll see
some data that I pulled.
This is some testing that I
had done a few months ago,
but a couple key points to call out here.
On top of the fact that
the Fabric Cloud Router
is completely private
and operates across our
Equinix private network,
we do also have what we call IPWAN,
or it's the IP VPN network.
It's a true
multipoint-to-multipoint network.
And I can interconnect
my Fabric Cloud Routers
across different metros within,
let's say, North America.
I can also extend into
EMEA and APAC as well.
So I have both regional and
global network constructs.
I can set the speed or
throughput that I want on those.
And in this particular example,
I've got a cloud router
that's deployed in Seattle,
and I've got one deployed in Ashburn.
I'm connecting to AWS on the West Coast,
and I'm connecting, in this
case, to GCP on the East Coast.
I have 10-gigabit virtual connections,
so this is a AWS-hosted Direct Connect,
as well as Google's counterpart there
with regards to Cloud interconnectivity.
And then I've got two virtual
machines, one on each end.
And going from West Coast,
all the way to East Coast,
between 63 milliseconds
or around on average.
A couple things to call out here.
When we're doing interconnectivity
between these metros
and going across our private network,
rather than going across the internet,
we effectively have
four predetermined hops.
I have my Direct Connect gateway.
I've got my cloud router,
my second cloud router on the
other side of the country,
and then my Google cloud router
on the other end of the connection.
Beyond that, obviously,
there's the endpoints
or the IP addresses of the actual VMs,
but it's extremely predictable.
Whereas if I'm going over the internet,
I can run two different trace routes
and I may take completely different paths.
It may be somewhat unreliable
or essentially best effort, right?
So there's a lot of predictability
in terms of performance, jitter.
So for latency-sensitive applications,
even across longer distances,
we see a lot of success there as well
with Fabric Cloud Router
and our Fabric network.
Taking it a little bit further down,
customers should expect to see line rate
across this connectivity.
There's still layer
two connectivity there,
and with the Fabric Cloud
Router, we're just building
layer three connectivity on top of that.
So in this particular example, you'll see,
if you're familiar with iPerf,
these are two very, very small VMs
with my only criteria being
they could do 10 gigabit out.
So the VM size, number of vCPUs,
frequency and amount of
memory is extremely limited.
So you'll see, I ran 100
parallel threads with TCP
and changed the congestion algorithm
because I was going across
either end of the country,
and it was completely
saturating my virtual machines.
But we were able to achieve
9.5 gigabit per second
on one end and 9.26 on
the other end as well.
And then on the bottom
there, when I'm using UDP,
a lot less, no congestion there,
and you'll see that I effectively hit
very, very, very close
to what I would expect
to get line rate with 63
milliseconds of latency.
And you'll see on the very,
very bottom, actually,
I'm not running multiple
parallel threads there,
and you'll see 9.89 gigabit sent,
and I'm only getting 4.92 back,
and I'm simply running into
single flow limitations
with connectivity on the return path.
So that's not a limitation
on the cloud router.
It's just an AWS networking
single flow limitation.
If I was to run parallel threads there,
we could saturate the
whole thing, no problem.
The last thing we'll kinda talk about
is some customer case studies.
The first one here is gonna
focus on speed and agility,
and then the second one we're
talking about is raw scale.
Right, so we had a customer
approach us some time back.
This is completely new.
They had heard of Equinix.
They weren't currently using Equinix.
They came to us and said,
hey, we're deployed in AWS
on the East Coast.
We recently acquired a company.
We work in the financial
services industry,
particularly in automotive loans,
and one of the products
that we participate in,
the dealers will query
out when an individual
is looking to purchase a vehicle,
and they'll reach out to
multiple institutions,
and it's almost kind of a race
to see who responds back first,
and it kinda goes down in a list.
What they were aiming to do
is move higher up in the list
in terms of how quickly they can respond.
If that person was approved for the loan,
they could respond quickly,
get closer to the top of the list,
and therefore may have more success
with the dealership
selecting their institution.
This particular morning,
I jumped on a call with a salesperson.
They said, hey, I'm
talking to somebody new.
Can you help me out?
I said, yeah, sure.
And so I talked to
somebody for about an hour.
This was about 8:30 in the morning,
and then by 12:30 in the afternoon,
he had reached out and said,
Yeah, I got it deployed, it works.
So within four hours,
somebody who had never even
had an account jumped in,
went through our process,
and in this case, they went
through our marketplace,
which I'll share about
in just a moment as well,
some more about that,
but effectively met us for the first time,
kinda gave him some direction,
and then he went off and running,
and later that afternoon was
extremely, extremely happy
with his ability to
interconnect AWS with Azure.
And in the second case study here
is an autonomous vehicle company
with some huge requirements
in terms of data that
they're transferring,
so autonomous vehicles
collecting data periodically,
multiple fleets of
vehicles across the country
that effectively totaled
500 terabytes a day
that they needed to transfer
into a mixture of S3
and other public clouds.
And this customer,
one way that we helped
solve this for this customer
across the country
was having a physical
presence in the data centers
in the regions that they had
their autonomous vehicles,
and then utilizing AWS Direct Connect
with multiple 25 gigabit
circuits, virtual connections,
to move that data into AWS.
And we were able to successfully
do this for the country,
excuse me, for the customer,
and even with the ability for
that fleet to require moving
because of the number of data centers
that we have across the country,
it's worked extremely
well for that customer.
And then finally, as I
mentioned a moment ago,
we do have a seven-day trial
of our Fabric Cloud Router
that is available on AWS Marketplace.
If you're interested in
multi-cloud connectivity,
hybrid multi-cloud, and
wanna give it a try,
it's our full standard paid version,
but it's free for seven days,
and it comes with two 200
megabit virtual connections
that you can turn up.
If you'd like to use a smaller speed
or a lower speed as well,
down to 50 megabit, you
can do that as well.
Last thing I'll mention is
I'm happy to answer questions.
We have a booth that's actually
right behind the pavilion here, booth 335.
If you'd like to come by
and ask any questions.
Otherwise, I think we're good.
- Thank you, and please do take a moment
to give us survey feedback as well.
It should be in your apps.
Thank you very much.
- [Brandon] Thank you.